[Musica]
e quindi ragazzi oggi
sembra tg1 trovato il nuovo youtuber fa
vj vabbè comunque ai capelli quelli
lunghetti bene lunghetti belli punti ma
parlando di estrema unzione la gente mi
mi guardava e sono grato di questo mi
volevano bene ha detto guarda che
poverino
così via un po per penn avrebbe destra
vediamo di provare a fare una reaction
al primi video del mio canale ma non lo
so sono numeri ma io prima
ma comunque vediamo di riuscire a fare
questa reaction senza che linciare
troppo ragazze bellissime adesso
sognando essendo stato iniziato vai
subito vedi questo tasto qua perfetto e
di schiacciarlo immediatamente
bravissimo i pieni di non hanno neanche
la copertina pigro proprio pigro bella a
tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo blog e io sono fa vj psi come sono
via voglio solo te mi quadra delle posta
cia bravi ragazzi ai baci abbracci non
dormivo prevediamo parast occhiaia e
delineabile bellissimo terrorizzato a
morte questo qua questo qua sto ti prego
era uno sponsor praticamente bacia bravo
uno sponsor ammazzano che allegri ha
costruito dice ok ok
mi cacciano pensiero non si vedeva
niente c'è la maggior parte dei video
che inquadrato il buio tutti i video
così c'è niente
ammazzò che allegria suo posto
ok
ma com'era scritto a distanza di dieci
anni è riuscito a prendere l'infarto da
un video in un video e non fosse
spaventata ma che cosa eccolo 410 mila
iscritti vicini
[Applauso]
è
vero come era un casato quando giocavo è
proust ragazzi era bello andare molti di
voi mi hanno chiesto di materializzare
me stesso però ragazze io scrivo dei
nomi veri lui non può materializzare
questo ovviamente era fake lo facciamo
in questo canale un po di
intrattenimento ma non sono mancati
e come lo so bisogna provare a mandarlo
a quel paese visitato il covip altro
come lo mesta scusiamo paperina
tik tok prima di tik tok a c'è posta per
fa vigenti metti uno dei pacchi il primo
pa questo è il primo pacco aperto nei
unboxing non mi ricordo cosa c'è
non
voglio qui perché veramente buon gioco
cioè dicevo perché non avevo una sorta
di demone dentro che non c'è più adesso
è bellissimo vediamo che a farlo ma è
fantastico ragazzi lo spoglio quadro
proprio no
[Risate]
o qualcosa e la cosa
ma secondo me questa è l'acqua che
adesso unico si si io per me adesso io
non riesco a guardare parte che non
riesco a guardarmi guardami io per
questo motivo non riesca riguarda i miei
video vecchi perché se guarda i video
vecchi io parlo così amy green già non
ce la faccio capito quindi devo trovare
un momento di
capire cessare questo è il video che
avevo messo ha messo gli spezzoni di
questo video anche quando fatto video
con diletta parte ci divertiamo un sacco
e questo sicuramente ma la squadra in
infortuni ma stiamo scherzando
ma guardate st scena qua le teen tira
una ginocchiata e poi tirato il guardone
mignolo sul mio letto
attirato una pedata al letto e poi la
testata al muro tutti e due insieme già
incredibile è stato uno dei tipi
divertenti comunque il mio canale stava
decollando video fortissimo speciale 150
mila e io ero innamorato perso ma
infatti io lo dico sempre diretta cioè
nel senso per me mi ha accompagnato nel
periodo più bello della mia vita grazie
diletta è grazie a voi per avere reso
questo possibile abbiamo fatto il
momento strappalacrime io sono come
emozionato
questo era uno dei primi favi rispondere
ai miei capelli facevano questo partiva
il capello arrivava qua i capelli
sapevano starmi per coprire gli occhi
perché hanno vita avevano vita e
facevano creavano questo ondina non la
facevo io l'ondina te lo giudice di un
così caffe te lo giuro su dio gli i
capelli no i capelli mi facevano
l'ondina una volta arrivati qua da soli
sarete i miei occhi
ok ragazzi ci siamo questo ad ora a nov
adesso sognando fatto vedere la mia
camera e questo come potete vedere non è
un castello mega galati mi manca la mia
camera con i ragazzi
raga io questo avevo avevo questo io
avevo questa roba questa non set up da
youtuber serio ai tempi perché se non
aveva anche questo ma ho capito perché
parlavo sempre così
ma centro iniziale video quella ragazza
del livello che avete fatto già notare
sì bravo che in quasi integra articolo
il pannolino no facevo le pulizie
no in un fumavo
io no io avevo la mania di fare la
collezione di tutto capi pacchetti di
sigarette pacchetti di chewing gum io
facevo collezioni cose quindi non ho non
fumo non ho mai fumato non fumo per chi
lo chiede non mi fa fare il mio schifo
proprio sulle
casse ci sono questo bastò per avere
stoffa perché il green gelo lo
commentiamo questo è un regalo che mi ha
fatto una ragazza la parola friends on
ancora non era chiara ti voglio bene che
non è indifferente da da siamo molto
differente la ti amo sai cosa devi
mettere sul cuore adesso
no ci dissociamo penso che mi conoscono
sono fuori j faccio video su youtube
trapani j scusate ma mi ha passato un po
ma ricordo da parte velocissimo che
adesso pareggio
va beh lo sapete
passiamo di 40
la via di qui le scarse successo erano
bei video belli intrattenevo ero bravo
però in età io non riesco a uguale è
come quando riguardato i vostri post del
2009 ok a meno che non siete nati nel
2009 grigia te e per me è la stessa cosa
perché su youtube dieci anni fa era un
ragazzino quindi io non riesco a guarda
non riesco a guardarmi non mi riesco a
guardare magari voi dite no bellissimo
ci sta
chapeau poi ogni tanto andato a rivedere
questi video e mi fa molto piacere ma io
non riesco a ricordarmi
ma che sia anche che che cacchio di
disegno è un disegno pazienza credibile
un segno pazzesco questo il primo video
sul gol simulator lui di core
impressionante finale dei mondiali si
sbagliano sono uscita sbagliare a porta
vuota se penso che l'abbiano programma
life parma pensa che abbiano programmata
possa per farla sbagliato riesca a
leccare più cose di miley cyrus anche
anche i camion mi
dissocio perché ai tempi lei leccava le
menti nello imprevisti nogoal school e
tornerà il gioco proprio per me io
cantavo sui bug dei giochi grazie
militare un gioco fatto sui bug stanno
facendo il 3 bellissimo visto entrare
fatti allora io non faccio più gameplay
[Musica]
io
forse ci possiamo fare il fatto che non
faccio perché impegno vuol dire che io
non possa fare ogni tanto una mano a chi
qualche piccola eccezione ma vedremo
quindi ragazzi erano un tentativo di
reaction nel senso che stiamo testando
stiamo testando per vedere come viene
però che bello e se provo divertenti so
che è piaciuto è bello oggi fare video
che mi piacciono porca vacca e
bellissime posso concludere dicendo una
cosa avrò avuto un pessimo look estetico
avrò avuto una pessima voce avrò avuto
pessimi gusti in ambito di vestiario
no niente basta